a Kentucky woman who volunteered for a
group that helped find missing people is
now the focus of an intensifying search
after she vanished
Andrea Knable disappeared more than two
weeks ago
mark Strassmann spoke to her family and
he joins us now from Louisville mark
what a strange story what did the family
have to say good morning this is the
residential street where her family
believes Andrea Knable was headed she
never made it she disappeared which is
why you'll find this poster looking for
her all over this area
Andrea cam Abel's family goes
door-to-door searching for hope we
really appreciated Knable a 37 year old
single mother of two disappeared August
13th
she left her sister's house upset and
was last seen talking on her cell phone
walking toward her mother's house about
a half-mile away well it's not the same
right now without her
Aaron feckers her sister Mike Knable is
her father they told us Andrea had
recently lost her job and was going
through a rough patch it was a total
disappearance no one's heard anything
ever since nothing just randomly it'll
hit you or you get really upset and I'm
hoping that she didn't come out on a
busy thoroughfare like this and take a
ride with someone to go to someone
else's house and never made it it got
into the wrong car and that's the worry
hmm that's the worry a volunteer group
called missing in America has joined the
search
this is very personal personal to Diane
stump because Andrea Knable belongs to
their group I've looked up the map and
it's about 13 miles away from here this
is Knable around five months ago in Ohio
helping search for someone else who was
missing it's heartbreaking we miss her
and we're gonna find her we're gonna
keep looking till we do do you feel in
your gut having done this hundreds of
times they'll be a happy ending I pray
to God that there'll be a happy ending
but it's been more than two weeks with
no sign of her just the more time that
passes around worried that this is it
and maybe that was the last time I was
going to see her so I'm very worried
Louisville police told us they also have
no leads like Andrea can Abel's family
they just hope somebody knows something
and we'll get in touch Gail
yes mark well are all hoping they're
having now that they will have a happy
ending on this story thank you very much